خطه عمل جديده طرحتها حكومه ريشيسوناك
لمواجهه ما تسميه السلوك المعادي للمجتمع
فضمن اصلاح قطاع ايجار السكن سيكون بوسع
ملاك المنازل طرد مستاجريهم الذين ينتهكون
معايير السلوك الاجتماعي كالحفلات الصاخبه
او الطاعات المخدرات او يتاخرون في سداد
ايجارهم
اصلاحاتنا صحيحه ومتناسبه ومتوازنه وسنعمل
على تقويه اسسها وعلى اصحاب العقارات
استخدامها لاستعاده ملكيتها بما في ذلك
عندما يكون المستاجرون مخطئين
الائتلاف الصحي للمستاجرين لطالما دعا
الحكومه الى تعديل نظام الايجار لحصول
مستاجرين على مرافق مناسبه وصالحه
لاستخدام والغاء طردهم دون سبب مع انشاء
هيئه لتسويه النزاعات بسرعه
اعتقد ان احد اهداف هذا التشريع كما تقول
الحكومه هو اعاده التوازن للنظام لصالح
المستاجرين بشكل طفيف لان اصحاب العقارات
في الوقت الحالي يتمتعون بالكثير من القوه
في التصرف في ممتلكاتهم ويعود سبب ذلك الى
الطلب الكبير جدا على العقارات المؤجره
بموجب نهج عدم التسامح المطلق سيتم حظر
غاز اكسيد النيتروس المعروف بغاز الضحك في
رساله واضحه الى عصابه التخويف التي تتجول
في الشوارع الرئيسيه والمنتزهات وتغمرها
بمخدر العبوات الفارغه وتزعج النسب
بسلوكها المعادي تعتبر الحكومه خطه العمل
المناهضه للسلوك الذي ينتهك حق الفرد في
العيش بامان امرا بالغ الاهميه ولن تتوانى
في تعاطيها مع الجريمه والسلوك المزعج
الذي يسبب البؤس للناس مصطفى العربيه لندن